[Music]
which of these has the least
carbohydrates this roll of bread this
bowl of rice or this can of soda
it's a trick question although they may
differ in fats vitamins and other
nutritional content when it comes to
carbs they're pretty much the same so
what exactly does that mean for your
diet
first of all carbohydrate is the
nutritional category for sugars and
molecules that your body breaks down to
make sugars carbohydrates can be simple
or complex depending on their structure
this is a simple sugar or monosaccharide
glucose fructose and galactose are all
simple sugars link two of them together
and you've got a disaccharide lactose
maltose or sucrose
complex carbohydrates on the other hand
have three or more simple sugars strung
together
complex carbohydrates with three to ten
linked sugars are oligosaccharides those
with more than ten are polysaccharides
during digestion your body breaks down
those complex carbohydrates into their
monosaccharide building blocks
which your cells can use for energy
so when you eat any carbohydrate-rich
food the sugar level in your blood
normally about a teaspoon goes up but
your digestive tract doesn't respond to
all carbohydrates the same
consider starch and fiber both
polysaccharides both derive from plants
both composed of hundreds to thousands
of monosaccharides joined together but
they're joined together differently and
that changes the effect they have on
your body
in starches which plants mostly store
for energy in roots and seeds glucose
molecules are joined together by alpha
linkages most of which can be easily
cleaved by enzymes in your digestive
tract
but in fiber the bonds between
monosaccharide molecules are beta bonds
which your body can't break down fiber
can also trap some starches preventing
them from being cleaved resulting in
something called resistant starch
so foods high in starch like crackers
and white bread are digested easily
quickly releasing a whole bunch of
glucose into your blood exactly what
would happen if you drank something high
in glucose like soda
these foods have a high glycemic index
the amount that a particular food raises
the sugar level in your blood
soda and white bread have a similar
glycemic index because they have a
similar effect on your blood sugar but
when you eat foods high in fiber like
vegetables fruits and whole grains those
indigestible beta bonds slow the release
of glucose into the blood those foods
have a lower glycemic index and foods
like eggs cheese and meats have the
lowest glycemic index
when sugar moves from the digestive
tract to the bloodstream your body kicks
into action to transfer it into your
tissues where it can be processed and
used for energy
insulin a hormone synthesized in the
pancreas is one of the body's main tools
for sugar management when you eat and
your blood sugar rises insulin is
secreted into the blood it prompts your
muscle and fat cells to let glucose in
and jump starts the conversion of sugar
to energy the degree to which a unit of
insulin lowers the blood sugar helps us
understand something called insulin
sensitivity
the more a given unit of insulin lowers
blood sugar the more sensitive you are
to insulin if insulin sensitivity goes
down that's known as insulin resistance
the pancreas still sends out insulin but
cells especially muscle cells are less
and less responsive to it so blood sugar
fails to decrease and blood insulin
continues to rise
chronically consuming a lot of
carbohydrates may lead to insulin
resistance and many scientists believe
that insulin resistance leads to a
serious condition called metabolic
syndrome
that involves a constellation of
symptoms including high blood sugar
increased waste circumference and high
blood pressure
it increases the risk of developing
conditions like cardiovascular disease
and type 2 diabetes
and its prevalence is rapidly increasing
all over the world as much as 32 percent
of the population in the u.s has
metabolic syndrome
so let's get back to your diet whether
your food tastes sweet or not sugar is
sugar and too many carbs can be a
problem
so maybe you'll want to take a pass on
that pasta sushi roll pita burrito donut
burger sandwich
[Music]
you